new video shows that deadly shootout
involving two bounty hunters inside a
Texas car dealership that cell phone
video captured Tuesday's gunfight that
left three people dead David Beck knows
outside the dealership it's in
Greenville Texas and that's near Dallas
David good morning Gail good morning
from this vantage point looking back at
the dealership you wouldn't know there
was a shootout here but Tuesday morning
the two bounty hunters showed up there
was a fugitive inside that they were
looking for they waited several hours
then moved in but the fugitive was well
prepared he had a handgun that he
apparently pulled in the bounty hunters
but dropped all three men go for the gun
there's a shootout and it lasts less
than six seconds cell phone video shows
the moment two bounty hunters tried to
apprehend Ramon Hutchison inside this
Greenville Texas car dealership they
approached with guns drawn then about 20
shots rang out
the shootout shattered windows and sent
customers running Hutchison was killed
along with FNG security and
investigation employees Fidel Garcia jr.
and Gabriel Bernal the 49 year old
Hutchison had an outstanding warrant for
failure to appear on a first-degree drug
charge in Minneapolis Minnesota Bernal
and Garcia had traveled to Greenville
from Corpus Christi Texas to arrest
Hutchison were charged with the task of
apprehending people who failed to appear
in court Stu Peters is a bail
investigator who helped track Hutchison
he then handed the investigation over to
Fidel Garcia jr. the target was
potentially going to be in the
Greenville area he then called me a
little bit later on and said that he was
gonna be at a car dealership and that
was last I heard from him in Texas a
bounty hunter usually carries handcuffs
and a gun but cannot pretend to be an
officer they do have the authority to
make arrests but only with written
authorization from a bail bondsman you
get into situations that sometimes it's
hard to get out of dusty Steele was a
bounty hunter for 16 years it's very
dangerous because you don't you don't
have the police authority being a bounty
hunter the owner of the car dealership
told The Associated Press that the to
bail bondsman identified themselves as
federal agents to the car dealerships
general manager and a receptionist we've
not been able to independently verify
that but Charlie a friend of one of the
bail bondsman did say he would never
misrepresent himself like that thanks
David